benvenuti in un nuovissimo video il
video di oggi è uno di quei video che mi
chiedete da tantissimo tempo e non so
per quale motivo non l'avesse ancora
fatto perché capite il mio amore
incondizionato nei confronti delle borse
signore e signori è arrivato il momento
di mostrarvi la mia amatissima
collezione di borse e brasile sono
sicura che chi mi segue da un po di
tempo riconoscerà alcune di queste borse
con i relativi aneddoti i nuovi
spettatori e cioè i mariners che non si
sono ancora iscritti al canale ragazzi
iscrivetevi subito il canale perché sto
per arrivare al milione e ho bisogno
anche di voi dovrò un attimino
riassumere questi aneddoti
partiamo subito ogni borsa avrà un nome
un hashtag questa borsa è senza ombra di
dubbio la prima borsa firmata la mia
prima bambina
stavo giusto notando che è in alcuni
punti
ovviamente rovinata perché l'ho messa
tantissimo ragazzi è veramente una delle
borse che utilizzato di più brevemente
la storia qual è mi è stata regalata per
i 18 anni
io abitavo ancora torino ma ero venuta a
milano comprarla vi ricordo ancora nel
negozio in galleria di gucci però super
decisa perché c'era ti sei piacevano
alla fine ho creato per questa
essenzialmente per il colore perché
ovviamente in nero sta bene su tutto non
per altro aumentato il mio weber oberhof
è un pezzo storico e sarà una di quelle
borse che farò vedere che probabilmente
imprese rho con molta parsimonia a
i nipoti che ogni volta sarà un colpo
passiamo una borsa che tanti di voi
riconosceranno subito ormai famosa
questa borsa nel web
questa volta l'ashtag e sarebbe la prima
borsa firmata che ho comprato ma troppo
lungo quindi primo acquisto
la pedina ve la ricordate vero
lo so che è anche la storia ve la
ricordate
ho acquistato questa volta quando parate
facevo ancora i saldi cerco di
riassumere in ogni caso se volete la
storia in ogni suo dettaglio vi lascio
qui il video mi innamoro di questa borsa
ero lì con telefono mia mamma col mio
ragazzo perché non riuscivo a decidere
la prendono prendono prenderò la prendo
nel momento in cui ho deciso di
prenderla una ragazza cinese si avventa
su di essa convinta di prenderla io
guardo la commessa che sapeva benissimo
che stavo scegliendo e quindi non era
ancora libera gelo con uno sguardo e
dico che dobbiamo fare è che la lei di
ecco praticamente alla fine sono
riuscita forse questa cosa mi ha
convinto ulteriormente a prenderla più è
difficile avere una cosa più ovviamente
ti viene voglia di averla l'asta che è
il primo acquisto ma poteva anche essere
la borsa contesa anzi mi piace di più
cambiamo è prima questo ha la borsa
contesa ci sta il telefono il power bank
le chiavi case di portin lucida labbra
un pacchetto di fazzoletti e difficile
da chiudere
devi scegliere o ti soffia il naso o
carichi il telefono o rimani fuori casa
passiamo a quella che definirei il
regalo di compleanno anche questa ve la
ricorderete bene la mia prima il saint
laurent desiderata tantissimo è stato il
mio regalo di compleanno non mi ricordo
di quanti anni fa
2 inutile dirvi che laurito sempre tutti
i giorni
se posso dire una cosa col fatto che io
porto sempre in giro tantissime cose è
un po pesantuccia cioè già senza niente
dentro al suo peso
con portafoglio la urban telefono e
succhia passiamo a quella che definirei
l'ha sottovalutata
ti spiego subito il perchè quando ero
una bambina ragazzina a questa borsa la
usava mia mamma e io la snobbavo
abbastanza perché non mi faceva
impazzire
se hai fatto che nel passaggio tra nome
prendete le borse firmate a come dolori
alla borsa firmata o inizia penso mai
interessarmi soprattutto alle borse di
questo brand ma vi assicuro che non ho
mai voluto manifestare questa borsa
perché la consideravo pacchiana quando
la quando la vedrete mici di rete tutte
perché etico wow pronte a ovviamente
adesso è diventata mia allora chiariamo
dei punti
effettivamente strà tornata di moda ai
tempi non apprezzavo tanto questa catena
oggi di comaschi e bellissima cioè nel
senso la metto tutti i giorni cioè ciao
mamma questa borsa rivedrai mai più
recente passiamo uno degli ultimi
acquisti quindi ve lo ricorderete molto
bene come lo chiamiamo la borsa marsupio
ebbene sì è proprio lui o lei io non so
mai come definirlo perché effettivamente
si può mettere in entrambi i modi
l'omessa tantissimo e super adattabile a
qualsiasi tipo di look e micro proprio
come la prada telefono già al power ben
o chiavi dice poi rischiare di stare
però gatti è bellissima e la votanti
simo la sta usando tantissimo acquisto
di cui sono super soddisfatta basta nero
basta noi possiamo più passiamo delle
borse di altri colori questo la
definirei l'invidiata perché l'invidiata
perché anche questa è la mia mamma che
era già entrata ufficialmente nella fase
voglio anch'io può uscire col e borse
firmate la guardava ogni volta sperando
che si stancasse riutilizzare questa
borsa a una certa basta c'è di la tua
figlia
gente no non c'era niente da fare quindi
me la sono dovuta sudare con anni e anni
della mia vita è bella
io tra l'altro mia madre l'aveva
acquistata con la cintura sa che si è
affatto la cintura mamma dove non è
messa cintura scusa dammi un colpo di
telefono a quanto la trovi è sicuramente
più capace un burrocacao ma che bello le
borse che non usi tutti i giorni ti
regalano sempre grandi emozioni che sa
quanti anni fa ho comprato questo se
anche voi non vedete l'ora che vostre
amate viceda le sue borse firmate ci
vorrà del tempo ma prima o poi saranno
vostre passiamo alla regalata regalata è
una borsa meravigliosa che ai tempi però
si parla di un po di anni fa non avevo
capito fino in fondo non avevo colto il
suo potenziale che è molto alto è una
céline e ovviamente non mi faceva
impazzire il colore per un semplice
motivo perché a differenza del nero o
comunque del belice come pari all
pensavo fosse un po più difficile da
abbinare il non è vero ragazze sbagliate
questo colore super abbinabile lo potete
mettere con tutto era fissata col fatto
che borsa e scarpe dovessero essere lo
stesso colore e mie ragazze
la moda vera e abbinare cose che non
c'entrano nulla ma che nel complesso
stanno bene ecco un altro degli ultimi
acquisti che anche questo ricorderete
bene lei
senza ombra di dubbio amore a prima
vista
che cosa non è quanto quanto è
meravigliosa ragazzi meraviglioso cioè
io la amo e stato amore a prima vista
nel senso che appena visto detto vabbè
la voglio anche se il mio dubbio era
anche qui sul colore perché ovviamente
avendo tutte le borse nere e usandole
sempre è il punto quando tu compri una
borsa in questo caso beige e riuscirò ad
utilizzarla quanto voglio utilizzarla la
risposta ci lasciano se dimenticate gli
abbinamenti cioè come una cosa del
genere poi anche uscire con un sacco
dell'immondizia perfetta la morte su web
ecco se il beige il marrone testa di
moro sono colori che magari inizialmente
ti possono spaventare ma poi non puoi
più farne a meno
ci sono dei colori che non dovrebbero
essere utilizzati per fare delle borse
[Musica]
come ti viene in mente di regalare una
borsa verde cioè io capisco che tu dici
magari marina una ragazza stravagante la
sobrietà prima di tutto però amore mio
non so se vedrai così spero
bella la metterei tutti i giorni ma cosa
che è passato per la testa quando hai
visto questo colore capisci che mi mette
in difficoltà perché io apro urea del
genere e dico bellissima ma
probabilmente la vernice rho con faccio
no scherzi a parte ovviamente a caval
donato non si guarda in bocca è una
borsa molto bella e anche comoda che
ovviamente utilizzerei di più se non
fosse di questo colore io veramente ho
delle difficoltà con il verde però c'è
da dire che appunto avendo i dettagli
neri
devo lavorarci su e devo sono anni che
ci lavora solo perché però ce la farò
magari a 50 anni pubblicano una foto
sinistra grandi ragazzi
ve la ricordate è come la chiamiamo la
la verde da verde vi ricordate la borsa
hashtag verde del video back collection
sono veramente riuscita a matera dopo 47
anni
purtroppo siamo arrivati alla fine del
video ogni volta voglio fare la persona
seria ma poi finisco per fare la
buffonata circo ma devi sapere con un
commento qui sotto quali tra queste
borse preferite in questo periodo sto
postando tantissimi contenuti anche su
tic toc e instagram quindi mi raccomando
seguitemi anche lì vi mando un bacione
norme ci vediamo al prossimo video